welcome to
[Music]
the space jam what's poppin rock stars
my name is mt and in honor of easter
weekend instead of spending quality time
with
slightly drunk vaccinated family members
watching small children struggle to find
very obviously placed brightly colored
plastic ovals warner brothers encouraged
us all to remember
that the real reason for the season is
to celebrate the resurrection of one of
the most
wholesomely righteous icons of all time
space jam
by officially challenging the world to
hunt down as many
king kong scooby-doo's and pennywise
as we can in the new space jam new
legacy
trailer and good god is space jam a
fitting name for this movie because a
new legacy
is truly jam-packed with so many
freaking warner brothers easter eggs in
such a small space
the trailer is literally only two and a
half minutes long and it already feels
like
ready player 1.5 in this if you
know me you already know how
irresistibly delicious i find a good
metaphorical movie easter egg compared
to those basic supermarket easter
eggs so you know your boy
had to make an attempt so buckle up
nerds we about to get into it and wow
not even
five seconds into the damn trailer and
we already see our first warner brothers
easter eggs with statues of marvin the
martian and doc from the animaniacs
standing majestically behind
nba superstar lebron jamies is that's
how you pronounce it right
it's libra on jammies right lebron james
oh
okay that sounds familiar so what
appears to be a warner brothers meeting
room of sorts and we can even see the
bee from the warner brothers logo
reflected in the background and then
when lebron and his fake movie son
dom gets sent to the wrong floor by a
mysterious elevator manipulating force
they find themselves in the warner
brothers horner 3000
server room which is a server room
unlike any other because most computer
server rooms
won't kidnap your freaking son using a
technology bubble that is clearly an
homage
to warner's terminator films most
computer survey rooms don't do that but
they should
they shouldn't don't kidnap somebody
else's son it's against the law just
don't kidnap people and because the
warner 3000 servers are being run by a
malicious rogue computer algorithm by
the name of
al g rhythm hey played by renowned
hollywood actor don cheadle
of donald duck and captain planet fame
captain planet mother
but before the don cheadle terminator
bubble kidnaps king james and sends him
flying through the various kingdom
hearts ass worlds of the server verse
lebron says
what in the matrix hell which is of
course another ruby property owned
by warner brothers and it even gets its
own little space jam world later on in
the trailer
and this is precisely when the warner
brothers easter egg madness begins as we
see lebron fly past the incestuous
stabby stab stab world of westeros from
game of thrones
orbit city from the jetsons bedrock from
the flintstones the land of oz for the
wizard of oz complete with tornado
action and this
black and white world over here which i
bet you is a reference to the old school
black and white warner brothers films
of old because back in the day films
used to be black and white
did you know that zack snyder didn't
invent it and speaking of old
warner brothers properties we also get a
look at 1941's
maltese falcon world as well as a whole
ass dc comics world as we can see
gotham and metropolis very prominent on
the surface
moving on when algae rhythm orders his
little buddy to send lebron to two world
in addition to planets from our solar
system like mars
saturn and neptune we see pete flip
through a number of warner worlds such
as gotham bedrock
themschira from wonder woman thundera
from the thundercats hogwarts from the
magic cats orbit city from the jetsons
westeros from game of thrones again and
emerald city from the wizard of oz and
of course
albuquerque now just to be clear warner
brothers has yet to conquer and own the
city
of albuquerque new mexico so i'm not
claiming it to be a warner brothers
property but albuquerque
is a reference to the famous bugs bunny
catchphrase i
knew i should have taken that left
albuquerque
and then as lebron falls towards the
roadrunner desert part of tune world he
of course falls through the warner
brothers rings at the beginning and end
of every classic looney tunes cartoon
and it even has the classic music you
know what i'm talking about
and while lebron james is trying to
think of people to add to his version of
the tomb squad lebron writes the names
of popular warner brothers characters
like superman gandalf king kong and the
iron giant
i'm sure he would have wrote godzilla
too if godzilla didn't have
well-documented internet beef
with somebody on the team i'm not gonna
name names but it's one of those people
and all of this while bugs bunny sits
comfortably behind him in a flying chair
while wearing marvin the martian's
helmet judging lebron silently as he
lists clearly inferior warner brothers
characters i mean superman
like how the hell is superman going to
help you in a basketball game huh what
the hell can superman do that speedy
gonzalez can't
nothing
[Music]
thank you so much to skillshare for
sponsoring this video and skillshare is
an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for curious
creative folks
like you skillshare lets you explore new
skills deeping existing passions and
just get
lost in all that creativity skillshare
offers classes designed for real life
learn and grow with short classes that
fit any schedule each class
is a combination of video lessons and a
class project and they have classes and
topics that new rockstars fans would
love like
animation film music and freelancing one
of their film and video classes that
looks really cool
is easy productivity tips for artists
taught by illustrator brooke
glasser the class covers the time
management skills you need
to quit procrastinating and get your
side hustle or creative project
done immediately now this is curated
specifically for learning meaning that
there are no
ads and there are always launching new
premium classes so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your creativity
takes you and it's less than ten
dollars a month with an annual
subscription that's crazy now the first
1 000 of our subscribers that click the
link in the description will get a
free trial of the premium membership so
that you
can explore your creativity so do it you
got to be in the first 1000 though so
hurry up but around a minute 40 into
this trailer is when things
really start to ramp up with the iron
giant almost getting some dang scooby
doo
on his shoe with of course dr moron's
evil scientist tower
looming in the background and a freaking
dragon flying overhead a dragon
that i suspect to be either drogon from
game of thrones or
smog from the hobbit movies but to be
honest and just gonna sound a little
racist but
all dragons sort of look the same i'm
gonna have dragons commenting in the
comments what do you mean all dragons
look to say you're cancelled empty
now the following moment in the trailer
lasts a whopping
two seconds long but they have managed
to still fit all of these freaking
warner brothers characters
into frames such as yogi bear and booboo
the flintstones like the entire family
the jetsons
jabber jaw penelope pit stop magilla
gorilla on a unicycle
captain caveman chatara from the
thundercats and migo from smallfoot
that movie that no one really watched
but we sort of remember it which is then
followed by
another shot that puts the 1933 version
of king kong front and center with those
little airplanes flying around him and
some other characters for the movie
small foot trailing behind him two of
which were voiced by lebron james
and zendaya who are also in this film
coincidence
not really they probably just i don't
know some people are warner brothers
and the cameos only get crazier because
we can see morpheus hanging out with an
agent for the matrix they wouldn't be
friends
i don't like this this isn't canon with
baby jane from the movie whatever
happened to baby jane as well as mr
freeze from batman and robin the wicked
witch of the west and a monkey from the
wizard of oz drogo from game of thrones
and pennywise from white kids are too
curious
the movie and the craziness does not let
up with this next
visually dense shot that includes cameos
of peter potamus
space ghost the scooby doo gang magilla
gorilla again
dino from the flintstones frankenstein
jr and buzz conroy penelope pitstop
king kong and of course the jetsons
flying around doing their thing and then
of course we are introduced to
lg rhythms goon squad which is comprised
of nba
and wnba players as well as lebron james
movie sun dom
as we see him sitting with them during
the big game but as one of those guten
squad members is showing off
surprise surprise we get even more
character cameos with some war boys from
mad max
60s and 89 catwoman just hanging out
together
jack nicholson joker the herculoids
including gleep and gloop and what looks
like
back to the future 3 marty mcfly in the
background but i'm not really sure it
looks like him though and when daffy's
jaw
drops to the floor we hear the classic
sound of an acme anvil
crashing to the ground which is a nice
touch
and immediately following we can see the
eiffel tower as a nod to 1942's
casablanca of course
we also get foghorn leghorns barn the
animaniacs tower and acme bomb building
the rising gorge from bugs bunny rides
again in the background towards the end
of this trailer as well
and of course we cannot forget to
mention that lola bunny hit us with that
d-wade tribute as she winks at the
camera
causing furries worldwide to all clean
their jeans
at the same time and finally some more
faces that we see towards the end of the
trailer are
blue falcon and dino mutt lionel and
chatara from the thundercats
jim carrey's the mask 60s joker and 66
penguin danny devito penguin mama
fratelli from the goonies and these
dudes from a clockwork orange i thought
this was a children's movie but sure
why not throw dr manhattan's blue penis
in there why not but those are all of
the easter eggs that i have located
in the new space jam new legacy trailer
are you guys excited for this new
michael jordanless sequel let us know in
the comment section below
also who is your favorite member of the
toon squad i'm very curious
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and please remember to support
this channel by checking out all of our
cool merch
at newrockstarsmerch.com and please
remember to follow me on social media
at mastertainment and be sure to follow
new rock stars everywhere that you can
because we'll be posting some dope
like fitness origins with philip molina
eric voss and tommy beck told doing all
sorts of cool
marvel inspired fitness stuff thanks for
watching everybody
everybody get up it's time to slam now
we got a real thing going now welcome to
the spaceship
[Music]
foreign